I love french toast I'm not really a
pancake kind of girl but I wanted to
make it a little more decadent so this
is I'm preparing today is a stuffed
french toast my name is Andrea drummer I
am the Executive Chef of the original
cannabis cafe in West Hollywood the
beginnings of this dish starts with
brioche bread when you're making the
slit to fill it go in the center so you
don't like tear the top but even if you
tear the top it's okay because you're
gonna brulee the top it's fine the idea
came from me wanting to just kind of amp
up french toast and kind of combine the
two things which is a bread pudding but
also at the brulee of like a traditional
creme brulee it's really exciting to
smell and watch you come together I'm
sure you're gonna love it I hope so
so you create that custard tips be
forgiving and enjoy it and have fun
because it is a very involved french
toast but the outcome is amazing and if
you make this for a few friends for
brunch and have a few mimosas you can't
go wrong it's better to leave the bread
out overnight so it gets a little crusty
that way when you soak it the custard
doesn't completely like macerate the
bread after the soap you're gonna bake
it meanwhile you are creating the
stuffing that's the cream cheese that's
Rakolta cheese that's also some fresh
strawberries and you're gonna bring that
mixture into a whip when that french
toast comes out of the oven it's gonna
be like piping hot so it has to be able
to withstand the French toast I would
normally eat this dish certainly for
brunch brunch is literally my favorite
meal
it's just that combination of sweet and
savory at one time and then you get to
enjoy a cocktail as well guilt-free with
that strawberries a little bit of lemon
zest then what we did is took like a
soft whipped cream we did a Chantilly
cream added a little sugar then you're
gonna whip it to just soft peaks not
stiff peaks because you're gonna want it
to kind of melt into the French toast
depending on your oven they not all
gonna be uniform necessarily so
panic it's okay some maybe a little
lighter and that's fine and then you're
gonna take the stuffing put that in a
piping bag if you get a tip make sure
it's big so those strawberries can pass
through then here comes the fun part
you take turbinado sugar and you
sprinkle it over the top and you're
gonna brulee it it's gonna smell so
amazing but I want to do again
immediately but hold off okay so then
you have a combination of berries
blueberries strawberries maple syrup
gonna mix that together gonna drizzle
that on top all the flavor is amazing
because you're getting that crunch of
the brulee you have the richness of this
brioche bread and then you have the
creaminess and decadence of the filling
which is not too sweet and then of
course the blueberries and the
strawberries that punch of like acidity
amazing you're gonna love it your
friends are gonna love it and they're
gonna be beating down your door for
brunch every week oh oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]